Related to interactive rendering, what the biggest surprise to you over the
past ten years? Is there any new capability, platform or social phenomenon that
has stood out in your mind?
&gt;&gt; I think that the way the games industry is really driving the graphics hardware
vendors is very interesting to me. I've gone through several cycles in my
career where the hardware goes from, let's have a separate card for graphics,
to let's put it back on the CPU to, let's go back out to, to the graphics card.
And it sort of has this, this cycle. And, now we're seeing the point where,
graphics cards have more power than the CPU, in many cases with, with all the
cores in them, and the program-ability. And the way that the vendors are
working together with the games developers and with the other developers, we
try to figure out what is going to keep programmable. And, as you know, if you
can turn a given algorithm into a fixed function and just, hard code into
transistors, you get much better performance like texturing.It's one of those
things where. Originally was programmable, but then they put it into a fixed
function to get the performance out of it. So working together with the
industry I really like the way that's going. I didn't see that as much 20 years
ago. with the card vendors. They were sort of on their own, but now they have
that collaboration going on.
&gt;&gt; I mean, I think, what we see with, you know, mobile and handheld devices is
really a big disruption and, you know, it has been amazing what's happening
here like how much the amount of rendering power you have like in your pocket
every day. And often I think like one way of, you know, just seeing how amazing
it is like if you sit down like in an airplane, where they have another of
those like touch screen devices, but it's often like five or ten years old
because you know the upgrade cycles for airlines is so long, it looks like
stone age technology compared to what you have in your pocket. So you know,
that, that's obviously something that is happening now, and it's, it's pretty
amazing.
&gt;&gt; With internet, I mean when I started doing rendering it was very much on a
desktop, you hit the Render button, and you came back the next day. And that
was like a big thing for me and a big problem. so now to see live interactive
web rendering is kind of blowing my mind. And I'm just, I know that soon we'll
be able to model and completely render lighted objects without having to you
know, hit the Render button and, and dread the results, yeah.